The little prince lives
on his asteroid B-612.
And he really likes
to watch the stars.
And what he really wishes
for is to watch the stars
while floating, to have
the best possible view
and to just immerse
himself in the stars.
And so the little
prince has to think
if there is a position
in space with respect
to other celestial bodies where
the gravitational force would
just cancel, so
that he can float.
Let's look at that.
So there is the planet
of the businessman.
We're going to give
it the mass m1.
And there is also the small
planet from the lamplighter
floating around with a mass m2.
And we know that gravitational
forces act radially.
So we can already see here that
if we put the asteroid B-612
somewhere here, then maybe
we find a constellation where
gravitational forces cancel.
So let's start by placing the
little asteroid over here.
And what is this body
experiencing in terms
of gravitational forces?
Well, it's going to experience
a gravitational force of object
1.
So we have object 1 or
F1m, due to the interaction
between object 1-- so
the businessman planet
and our little asteroid here.
And then we also, of course,
have the same direction
here due to the
interaction of object
2 and our little asteroid,
so that would be F2m.
And you can clearly see that
if we tally up these forces,
they're not going to add to 0.
So this is not a good location
for the little prince's
asteroid to be.
The same would be true
if we put it out here.
It will experience
those same forces again.
What do we have here--
1m and 2m just going
in the opposite direction.
But you have guessed it already.
We can find a spot here in the
middle where one force goes
in this direction.
So this is F2m.
And actually we should give
those forces direction.
And the other body
exerts a force
going in the other direction.
And so we can see
that we now just need
to find that exact position
here, in between these two
objects with two
different masses, where
the little prince can free
float while watching the stars.
We can say already that if
these two masses were the same,
it would obviously
be in the middle.
But because they
are not the same,
we have to calculate
what that distance is.
And so we're going to
label this distance here x.
And we're going to say
that the two bodies here
are a distance d apart.
All right.
How are we going
to go about this?
Well, we have to apply the
universal law of gravitation
in our F equals ma analysis.
Well, before we started with
our F equals ma analysis,
we actually have to pick a
coordinate origin and a unit
vector.
And so let's place the
coordinate origin in here.
And let's have i hat
go in this direction.
And we're going to label this
position A, and position B,
and position C.
These are our three
options for asteroid placement.
And well, let's
look at position B.
And well, we have
the universal law
of gravitation between the
mass of the object here.
And we'll have to
describe both components.
So first this one
F1m and then F2m.
And if we start with F1m, that
goes in the negative i hat
direction.
So minus Gmm1 on the distances x
squared in the i hat direction.
And then the other one goes
in the plus i hat direction.
And we have Gmm2.
And now we have d
minus x gives us
this portion-- d minus x squared
also in the i hat direction.
And that needs to add up to 0,
because that is what we want,
right?
If it adds up to 0, then we
have no gravitational forces
acting on the asteroid.
So now we need to
solve this for x here.
And in the first step, you
see that actually G and m
will fall out here.
And then we're
left with m1 over x
squared minus plus m2
over d minus x squared.
And we can write
that as m2 x squared
minus m2 d minus x squared.
And what you see here
is that this will
turn into a quadratic equation.
And if we do a few
steps of arithmetic,
and then write down
the general solution
to this quadratic equation,
we will find this here.
x equals 2dm1 plus minus 2dm1
squared minus 4m1 minus m2m1d
squared, and then the square
root of that over m1 minus m2.
And actually we
need two of those.
So we have this quadratic
equation here-- well,
the solution.
And we now need to consider
one more thing-- namely,
this equation here is
only valid if-- well,
can I write this here--
if x is between 0 and d.
Right?
In position C, my
x is larger than d,
which means this-- sorry,
this force here flips sign,
and then this
would be different.
So this plus here refers
to x being less than d.
And we have to decide
which of the two signs
here gives us the
correct, which will
fulfills this requirement here.
So this simplifies to x
equals dm1 plus minus m1m2
and here we have
the square root.
And then here, we have another
bracket over m1 minus m2.
And we need to get
this term here smaller
than 1, which will be
smaller than 1 if the x is
between 0 and d.
And as it turns out,
that is indeed true
if we use the minus sign here.